so today we're going to talk about
Jupiter lab which is the evolution of
the jupiter notebook but there's a lot
of names on this slide I just want to
point out so my name is Jason grout I
work for Bloomberg in New York it's
three of the main key players in in
Jupiter lab or Chris Culbert who has
worked for several years now developing
the foundation of Jupiter lab which
we'll see a little bit later as well as
sort of envisioning what the final
product might look like and helping
guide the architecture discussion so a
big shout out to Chris as well as Steve
and Darien who have been doing a huge
amount of work in actually developing
the code Brian Granger's southern Kuril
a camera and Olsen Fernando Perez David
Wilmer who also worked on Jupiter lab
for a while
Cal Poly students and the larger jupiter
team this is a huge effort and it's a
it's a it's a an effort to evolve the
jupiter notebook into something that's
even better than what we have today so
by quick show of hands how many people
know what the jupiter notebook is how
many people have used the jupiter
notebook okay so i won't preach the
choir too much this is jupiter notebook
is has taken the world by storm in some
sense it's a it's an interactive
environment that lets you do exploratory
data analysis and one of the key things
that brings to the picture is
reproducible document format that
combines code and narrative text
equations etc
it's built on top of the jupiter
platform which is a platform that
specifies protocols and messages and and
and reference implementations of tools
that allow us to connect to many
different programming languages in many
different environments and everything's
open-source bsd license for the benefit
of the video here's a short screen
capture of what the jupiter notebook
looks like today so where are we today
in project Jupiter we had a survey a
couple years ago we estimate we have
about three million users you'll see the
breakdown of the users that
we estimate and you see that science and
data science and education are well
represented up at the top and as well as
developers we have quite a number of
notebooks that are pervading the world
here's a huge amount of notebooks that
are on github in fact github and now has
rendering of Jupiter notebooks so it's
easy to view them we over 500,000
notebooks as well as a trending page on
github that you can go to see them
popular notebooks the Jupiter notebook
is enabling reproducible science so
here's one of the momentous discoveries
from the last a little while recently
the LIGO experiment has produced some
measurements of gravity waves and and
what was what was great is that they
published in and all their data in form
of Jupiter notebooks anybody in the
world could download their data play
with the data reproduce their analysis
amazing steps in enabling reproducible
science and and giving it to the masses
of course it was a quite sophisticated
analysis so we have other people in more
popular culture using Jupiter notebooks
to to share their data and analysis so
BuzzFeed in particular has been
publishing notebooks for their articles
here's an article on 10 the tennis
racket and the notebooks are all
available on github so we see the
notebook enabling people sharing their
data analysis not only in hardcore
science but also in popular popular
articles the Jupiter notebook of course
is more than just a notebook it's
evolved into some other building blocks
that are needed in data science we have
a file browser in the upper right a code
editor and upper left terminal and and
of course the actual notebook and we
have a few more notebooks a few more
building blocks in this this platform of
tools that you can use for the
scientific computation so a file browser
of course the other things that you've
seen kernels that allow us to talk to
many different languages Julia our
Python
and many many other languages as well as
a flexible output format in a way of
presenting output in a way that's
engaging in are interactive but these
building blocks are all comprising what
we now call the the jupiter notebook so
what are we hearing from users in this
survey that we mentioned before we asked
for feedback and we found that most
people use it daily or weekly so quite
often people love the notebook workflow
and the idea of a notebook environment
and the user experience of the notebook
but they pointed out a lot of needs and
we see these needs particularly when
people start to transition from a
notebook type environment to more hard
code coding environments we're taking
their data analysis from an exploratory
data analysis to building libraries
built on this and so things like
integration with version control systems
improved code and text editing instead
of just notebooks layouts being able to
put your code editor next to your
notebook or your terminal next to your
code editor next to your notebook in the
current notebook they can only be on a
single page each each thing is on a
single page can we have better
integration between these tools and also
tools that are more aligned with
software development debuggers profilers
variable inspectors etc so this brings
us to Jupiter lab and I just want to
emphasize that we're at the alpha stage
for Jupiter lab everything that you'll
see today is alpha preview level
hopefully we won't demonstrate that
hopefully you'll just believe me and
saying that Jupiter lab is a natural
evolution of the notebook you might say
it's an interactive development
environment where we have interactive
data analysis we have a flexible UI that
lets us assemble these building blocks
put them both side by side with each
other work between them in order to up
the power of the environment it's built
on a modern JavaScript architecture we
use NPM web pack
a plug-in system that was designed from
scratch we have model view separation
we're using types grid there's a bunch
of buzzwords for you the point is that
we're trying to take advantage of the
the current state of the art in online
architecture and development it's built
on phosphor jeaious which is a library
built by Chris culvert over the last few
years which enables the plug-in
architecture and some of the things that
we'll see later you can think of
phosphor J s as a as a collection of
components for a web application an
extensible performant web application
we've paid a lot attention to design we
have a few designers working with us
we've done user testing we're trying to
be really careful about the user
experience in this environment and
everything of course is open-source BSD
licensed all right let's see some demos
how many people were at site PI when we
gave a previous version of this talk how
many people listened to the talk online
it was published online okay great
those of you that were at site by a few
months ago where we announced this
originally you'll see some new stuff
everyone else you'll see a lot of cool
stuff here so when you launch Jupiter
lab you end up with an environment like
this and it has a number of the building
blocks that we mentioned before but in
more refined and powerful forms so over
on the left hand side we have a file
browser and the file browser lets us do
common operations like renaming the
leading cutting copying and pasting
files downloading files etc in fact in
order to move a file rename a file you
can click on the file to to rename it
you can move it by dragging and dropping
it you can drag and drop it into one of
these folders and you'll see there we
are a new fact you can even drag and
drop it up into the little directory
structure up there I'm sorry
these are files just like the Jupiter
notebook these are files served up by
the Jupiter server so wherever your
Jupiter server is running actually it's
whatever your contents manager which is
a plug up our pluggable part of the
Jupiter server whatever your conscience
manager is exposing to the to the UI I'm
going to open up a few files so we have
a code editor so here's a short
run-through of what we'll be talking
about today this is editing a markdown
file we also have a notebook so for
example here's a standard notebook this
is a slight modification of the widgets
examples and you know what do we need
more of on the internet but pictures of
cute cats and of course even better than
pictures of cute cats the pictures of
fuzzy green cute cats and you know this
is a standard notebook and just like the
normal notebooks we have interactive
controls so we can make the cat as cute
and fuzzy and green as we want yes sorry
font is a little bit bigger is that
better okay so so we have standard
notebooks that we see notebooks are
approaching feature parity with the
current notebook they're still our
niggling either bugs or minor user
experience issues but it's probably good
enough that a sophisticated user that
wanted to file bug reports could start
using it we also have a text editor so
here's a markdown file and here's the
Python file for example let me make it
just a little bit smaller because to fit
more on the page here we also have a
terminal so this is a full terminal and
we have a Python console actually a
console for any of the kernels and the
environment one plus three is four and
this is this is similar to the QT
console but in in a web format and with
all of these tools this is somewhat like
the state of the art with the current
notebook where you can have the
tools one at a time but we wanted to
enable something more powerful than that
so we allow you to drag and drop these
tools to whatever arrangement you would
like here so often you'll have a Python
file a terminal and a console side by
side and of course these are splitters
so you can change your environment
however you need we can also you know
just drag-and-drop experience works with
the file browser as well so here's a PNG
file we can drag it in put it wherever
we want and more than just arranging the
tools together the next step is to
actually make the tools work with each
other so as an example let me open up
this markdown file and this markdown
file has a bunch of text and and code
and what I want to do is actually run
the code instead of actually copying and
pasting it we can make this work a
little bit better if we start up a new
console in order to start up the new
console and introduce one more tool and
that is the command palette so as is
popular in many ide these days we have a
command Pollin that lists the commands
and keyboard shortcuts in the
environment has fuzzy searching so let's
see let's create a console for this text
editor Python 3 console and so this
console is hooked up to this text editor
so that I can just take this code and
I'm going to press shift enter and
you'll see it copies it over into the
into the console so what we have here as
an environment that many people are used
to and in other tools where you can work
with a text file it doesn't have to just
be a code file though it could be any
text file and code is automatically put
into the console it's a little hard to
see because it's cut off at the bottom
but there's an input right over here and
you can type in whatever else you want
you can interact with this console and
you have your interactive session over
in the corner of course you one line at
a time
is a little limiting but you can also do
entire blocks of code so here's an
import and say we're working through
this data so we have a data frame right
here and suppose we wanted to make a
scatterplot here's a scatterplot all in
line in the console so quite handy quite
nice to work with tools and work between
tools sometimes though you want to do
more than just see things over here in
the corner so what we've done is as well
as putting tools together and let you
use the tools together we also let you
take the tools apart so I want to just
maybe put this image up here so I can
see the image and I can drag any output
anywhere I want have a copy of that
output and now I can keep working in
this terminal here so here's my data
file my data and the image that copy of
that output stays where I want it and of
course this works as well with the
notebook if we go back to our previous
notebook this notebook example had an
interactive control here and often when
I'm dealing with the notebook I would
like to just have sort of a dashboard
type of environment and so of course I
can drag this output over here and now I
have a dashboard like environment over
here I don't have the notebook I just
have a copy of that single output as its
own entity and you see it's really a
copy of that output as I move the
sliders you see the sliders in the
original thing and they're in the
original notebook working as well of
course this leads to the following
workflow where I take this output
instead of dragging it over here I just
dragged this output right on top of the
notebook and now I have my dashboard
like environment from my notebook take
any output you want drag it on top of
that notebook and now you have an
environment that you can you know
arrange however you want use interactive
controls and and interact with here and
of course wouldn't be complete without
saying
this environment with four different
variables I'd get out the fun things and
use my game controller in order to
modify these sliders in real time here
so now we have simple dashboarding in
the in the notebook simple - boarding
capabilities question uh-huh yes so what
you'll see here is we used yeah a
question was if we have a number of
widgets can we arrange them all into a
single dashboard what we did here was we
use the interactive command and ipython
which automatically lays out several
sliders and the output of a function you
have a lot more advanced capabilities
for laying out widgets as well if you
can construct it into a single output
then you can drag that single output
wherever you want so you would use the
functionality from the widgets to layout
things however you want and then drag it
off to the side it's literally just
another view of that exact same output
it's just a copy of that output but set
apart from the notebook other questions
this is one of the exciting new things
and what's really exciting about this is
this was implemented at Sipan during the
sprints the bulk of it was implemented
in just a few hours by person that had
no Jupiter lab experience sitting down
with somebody that had experience but he
did the bulk of the code in just a few
hours and that shows some of the power
and the extensibility and flexibility of
this platform so the sky's the limit
here
let's go back to go back to our talk one
of the things that we see from that
example is that even people with little
or no experience with Jupiter lab or
JavaScript development can start to
customize the environment for their
needs and so one of the things that
we've tried to build is here is an
extensible platform with respect to file
types so you already saw that I could
drag a PNG file over and have a PNG
rendered this is provided by a plugin
that's a self-contained plugin but we
have more file more more sorts of things
than that closed down a few things here
for example here's that markdown file
that we just had and we can at the same
time view in a different way as a
rendered markdown file and so these are
connected to the same live model and you
can see that by you can see that it's a
live model of the the markdown files the
different views of the same markdown
file or linked together here so we have
live code editing code editing with with
the different views of the same file
mm-hmm yeah so question about
customizability can you change the CSS
actually we've one of the other new
things since I pie is that we've
introduced a complete theming for for
the environment that's based on CSS
variables and there's many many things
here that you can customize pretty
easily we don't have a built-in theme
editor yet but it's on the on the
roadmap plans but certainly you can
change the CSS and particular you can
change variables that are used all
throughout the platform to change
various looks and various elements but
of course it's open source so you can
change everything anything that you want
so one of the things that we do a lot
with it as data scientists is we work
with data and oftentimes we have things
like a CSV file or some data file and if
we want to see this file nicely then we
pull open the notebook and we we run a
command like read CSV here's the
standard IRS data set and we get a nice
display for this for this thing but if
we just want to look at the file opening
a notebook is pretty heavyweight so you
know the other option that we have is we
could open the file and just parse it by
hand here that's no fun
you could open it in Excel but then you
have to go to another tool
wouldn't it be nice if you could just
double click on the file and have a
table show up so this is a renderer that
renders CSV files in a way that looks
pretty nice for looking at it and
similarly what if you have you know the
weekend here Washington DC there's tons
of museums around here so of course it's
data geeks what we do is we download the
museums and DC geo JSON file and try to
plot out our route and you see here we
have their various museums and latitude
and longitude but it's very hard to see
where the museums actually are get a
sense for this data file so it wouldn't
be nice if you could just like double
click on the geogebra
this is the sort of power that we're
enabling here this this plugin was
written and largely written in about an
hour and a sleep deprived state a few
months ago and and lets us you know
easily take advantage of the leaflet
library to view a geo JSON file and
again it's live if I actually opened the
Geo JSON file you know I've always
wanted well when I learned about the
music poetry museum I mean the poetry
museum is amazing wouldn't it be nice at
the poetry museum was in say New York we
could just change this and you can see
that
ah oh well okay we could put the poetry
Museum in Pennsylvania and I guess but
the point is that there's a live a live
connection between these different views
of the file here so you have data files
you have rendered views of data files
and and they all work together are the
rendered view is what yes the rendered
views can be anything that you want we
have two rendered views here you can
easily make that map so you can drag
things around and it will update the geo
JSON file for example like this one yeah
so so this is actually an option that
someone came this to us and said I'd
like to do tab separated files and then
somebody else came along and implemented
delimiter and the code for this is
actually not that hard not that
complicated and it'd be easy to make a
little input Docs that would let you put
your own delimiter in yeah so the the
sky is the limit and this is a genius of
open source right that you can shape the
tools for whatever workflow that you
have this is the front end is entirely
written in pipe script which is a type
version of JavaScript yeah good question
the delimiter changing here what we're
using is we're using the d3 library for
parsing CSV files and the delimiter is
an option to d3 in order to it and so
what is what this is doing is it's
triggering a change and a function call
in JavaScript that's calling a d3 again
to parse the CSV file again and then
render the CSV file again
good question the question is can you
call Python on the server and actually
do some back and forth computation in
order to do that you'd need to hook up
to a kernel which is a little bit more
complicated we have ability to hook
kernels to text files we have the
ability to hook kernels to really any
viewer and so you would need to start up
a kernel and then you could interact
with a Python session in order to work
with the work with a view of a file yeah
so definitely possible that's what we're
doing in the notebook essentially even
things like here's a JSON file that is a
declarative description of a chart in
the Veiga format we've been
experimenting Brian Granger and Jake
Vander Plaats especially have been
experimenting a lot with this recently
but again we can just call the Vega
renderer and see that same JSON file
actually rendered using the Java Script
plotting library so flexible pluggable
renderers flexible plug pluggable views
on any file that that you want and the
sky's the limit here for what kind of
views and what kind of tools you want to
edit your files so I've mentioned this
several times but the exciting thing
about Jupiter lab is not so much the
tools that we're giving you it's that
we're giving you the platform to build
your own tools as well and this is
really the genius of open source that
you're you're welcome to dive as deep as
you want shape the tools to your heart's
content and just like Jupiter the
Jupiter notebook or even Jupiter lab the
exciting thing about the Jupiter project
is not so much the reference
implementations that we're handing you
if those are are awesome it's the
underlying protocol and messaging spec
that allows any number of tools interact
io and you know beaker and other
platforms to all engage in the same
ecosystem and and work together use the
same kernels etc and building the same
platform so everything is a plugin you
can see this by looking at the actual
code of Jupiter lab here's
the heart of Jupiter lab and you can see
here what we're doing essentially is
loading every component that you see in
the UI here as a separate plugin so for
example here's the notebook plug-in here
is the main menu plug-in everything here
is a plugin and every plug-in that you
write in the system is an equal
first-class citizen with every one of
these plugins and so for example the Geo
JSON editor is a third-party plugin it's
not one of the things listed here we've
developed it outside of Jupiter lab
we've installed it as a jupiter lab
extension and it participates with the
system on equal footing with every other
plugin in the system and plugins in
jupiter lab they can for example add
things to the command palette add things
to the menu add viewers for documents
like we've seen here for example with
the map they can expose other controls
so for example there's an experiment
writing a complete separate tab panel
that'll control or give insight into a
desk calculation perhaps there could be
another panel that controls a spark
cluster you know the sky's the limit of
what kinds of controls that you want to
enable here and you can participate in
the ecosystem in the jupiter lab
environment on equal footing with
everything else you can also expose
capabilities to other plugins so for
example the widgets that you saw with
the cat example that's a plug-in that's
installed into the system just like any
other plug-in that you would write and
publish on to pi PI and it exposes
capabilities for other people the write
widgets and build on top of the plug-in
that you've installed so we have a
flexible system of plugins every plugin
is exactly on equal footing with every
other plug-in you can mix and match you
can even delete plugins if you'd like to
make your own customized environment
that's really the power of Jupiter lab
here so the power of jupiter lab is the
community you guys i'm excited to see
what kind of plugins that you guys build
some examples of course of the Geo JSON
file handler we even have a cookie
cutter recipe for designing and
implementing starting out with a simple
plugin and then you can
you can take it to your heart's content
and really the big question is what will
you build with the Jupiter Lobby
ecosystem so wrap up quick wrap up today
Jupiter lab is early alpha preview only
I've taken to carrying band-aids in my
backpack sometimes you get caught on the
bleeding edge it's probably okay for a
really sophisticated user to start using
it and giving us feedback some of us
have started using it as our notebook
replacement as or as our computing
environment but keep in mind it's still
alpha which means that things are
changing rapidly designs changing
rapidly codes changing rapidly there's
dozens of pull requests merged in each
week so so so we're not suggesting it
for general usage yet the roadmap for
the future is we're going to have a
series of alpha and beta releases where
this is sitting alongside the current
notebook right now we release it as a
server extension so you install it into
the current notebook server and then you
have a new command Jupiter space lab to
launch it but it doesn't touch your
current notebook when we get to the
point where we think it's feature parity
and and ready for general usage then
we'll release Jupiter lab 1.0 maybe in
the first half of next year ish if
everything goes well and then we'll have
both the feature parity jupiter lab and
the jupiter notebook side-by-side and
and then it'll be ready for general
usage and then eventually the jupiter
lab will be the default UI and the
classic notebook will still be available
or possibly after a while available as a
separate download and it'll be
completely replaced with the jupiter lab
UI in order to install the Alpha level
preview remember you can either use pip
or Conda at the kanto for Japan Channel
pip installed Jupiter lab you have to
enable the Jupiter server extension if
you're installing from pip and then you
can do Jupiter space lab instead of
Jupiter's space notebook to launch the
lab or you can install it using Conda
which does the server extension enabling
step by itself I'd like to give special
thanks to the project Jupiter community
which includes not just the developers
but all of you and particular thanks to
the partnership this is all made
possible with a partnership between
Bloomberg my employer and continuum
analytics where Chris Kohlberg Steve
Sylvester and Darion work among others
and the Jupiter community and Jupiter
developers at large Jupiter of courses
supported a lot by the more Sloan and
Helmsley Foundation's particularly Bryan
Granger has been working a lot on this
project as well as a Cal Poly students
and he's hired have been doing a lot of
design work and encode work of course
Jupiter we'd like to give a special
thanks to num focus for their support
for the Jupiter project I if you want to
contact us we're pretty active on the
Gator channel if there's also the
jupiter google group or of course you
can go look at the code thank you very
much
i think we have time for some questions
yeah
not that I know of but we are really
hoping that somebody picks this up are
you any volunteers or welcome to join us
and and to work on some of these tools
like we said right now we've
concentrated a lot on building a feature
parity platform for and in a platform
that enables people to work on
individual components that are that are
useful so an object inspector a debugger
I'd love to see a debugger I'd love to
see a data browser of some kind there's
lots of tools that we would love to see
but I don't know if anybody is working
on an object inspector right now
the computational
what
so the question is the road map seems
like it's moving more towards IDE than
just the classic notebook where we had
just a single document on the page is
that a fair statement so so the question
is before we had document orient you
know story oriented documents and now we
have an IDE like environment and one
thing I'd like to emphasize is we're not
losing anything we still have the entire
notebook and the way it was you know
we're trying to get a feature parity
notebook that's still a story oriented
document format and you could just live
just with the documents if you wanted to
but what we saw was that people were
we're facing a lot of friction when
trying to move between a software
development stance where you're
developing libraries where you need a
text editor where you need a terminal
etc and people are having to sort of
pull these things in from other places
or try to get them as separate
applications to work with the kernel and
the server etc and bringing them all
into a single environment where they you
can interact now all sudden you cannot
just do story oriented documents but you
can interact between documents and a
text file and a library file and
documents and a console and so it's not
so much a departure from the notebook we
haven't we have and we've really value
that experience it's adding these other
tools and making everything work
together in an integrated way that we're
trying to Jim
so the question is how do you what are
the differences on the server side
bringing things into the architecture so
the thing about Jupiter lab is it's
completely on the client side completely
on the website on the on the browser
side the Jupiter server is exactly the
same we're running right now on Jupiter
notebook server for point two point
three and so there's no change on the
server side we might introduce some
changes as we see some limitations with
the Jupiter server with the expanded
capabilities we have on the web on the
browser side but Jupiter lab itself is
entirely a JavaScript application it's
just about interacting with the server
and the files that are already existing
on the server side no change to the to
the server side does that answer your
question it's a different web
application than the current notebook
but the server stays the same
mm-hm
yep that's a really good question one
thing that we that I didn't put on this
roadmap is working with third-party
extension authors like and be present
the question was what about the
extensions that we love know and love
from the current notebook like and be
present in other extensions that people
have written one of the things were
really concerned about and serious about
taking giving a lot of help for is in
this switch to Jupiter lab bringing
along the extensions either providing an
API that we can write to that will
enable both platforms or maybe more
likely helping authors migrate
extensions to the to the Jupiter lab
platform I think what we'll find is that
the Jupiter lab platform enables much
cleaner extensions and much more
powerful extensions than the old Jupiter
notebook and so we're we definitely want
to bring along the the extensions that
we know and love from the Jupiter
notebook one more question
good question multi-monitor support so
one of the things that's in the roadmap
for phosphorus so phosphorus the
underlying application shell and and and
widgets and and other libraries for
designing application one of the things
that we want to do in the underlying
phosphor library is make it so that any
one of these tab panels can be popped
out to a child window and then you can
move it to a separate monitor and it
would still be part of the same
application browser instance but living
in a separate window on your windowing
system and moves to a separate monitor
my question is about the security model
between the client and the server so
right now we're trying to preserve
feature parity with the notebook so we
have the concept two trusted notebooks
we have not done very much on the client
side on the browser side to enhance
security for example running things in
iframes and stuff like that we've been
trying to emphasize the feature parity
part first
but there's discussions on the table
about how do we run JavaScript code in a
sandbox context is it feasible to do so
we'd love to continue discussions if
you'd like to join us talking about
security ah question is about
authenticating okay so right so so
encrypting traffic for example between
the server authenticating to the server
these are really the purview of Jupiter
hub Jupiter lab just like Jupiter
notebook has no concept of users it's
just an application that's interacting
with a with a server Jupiter hub is one
that handles authentication for example
routing requests to various servers
depending on who's authenticated and and
what privileges people have and we're
working closely with the Jupiter hub
community to be able to integrate
Jupiter lab into that environment so
we're we're doing the sort of Jupiter
notebook part and integrating with the
other pieces of the Jupiter's system for
doing authentication and of course you
can run this on ssl to encrypt traffic
etc
Yeah right now we're the the front and
so the question is are there
opportunities contribute to Jupiter lab
in Python right now most of the work has
been done on the browser side here this
this typescript application there are
some changes that we would love to do to
the server to enable some more powerful
ways of interacting with things those
are places where we can jump in with
Python there's been small changes to the
Python server that we've needed to make
as we as we went along and and there's
more major changes to the Python server
that we would like to make but but we're
trying to get feature parity first and
then take a step back and look at okay
what server changes do we need so
definitely places that we can work on
the Python side come talk to me
we've got we've got some good ideas any
other questions
all right thank you very much and again
as users the cool thing about open
source is that you're not just users
you're developers too so thank you in
advance for all the wonderful plugins
and all the wonderful things that you're
going to create for the notebook and
rather the lab environment that I'll be
using so thank you